-Now, look.
Here's how it works.
Andrew, you will start the game
by pressing the start button
on this buzzer right here
And drawing a clue
from the top of the pile.
You don't need to get
rubbed down for this. No.
You have to get your teammate
to guess the clue
as quickly as possible
then hand the buzzer off
to the person on your right.
You can make any physical
gesture, say whatever you want,
but you can't say any word
in the actual clue.
If you're holding the buzzer
when it goes off
and it goes like -- BEHR! --
your team loses that round.
We'll play three rounds.
Let's take our positions.
Partner, you're over there, pal.
-All right. Great.
-Oh, God, this is awful.
-No. This is very exciting.
Come on. This is very good.
Now, Andrew, when you're ready,
press start and draw the clue.
-I press start
and draw the clue.
-And best of luck.
-Is everyone ready?
-I can't reach.
-Oh! Nice block!
That was bizarre.
[ Beeping ]
-I pressed start. I think I did.
A horse with a horn.
-A unicorn.
-You got it.
-Oh. No.
-Pick a clue.
-Okay. Sorry.
-No. Fine.
-Okay. The thing that you
communicate with people on.
-A phone.
-No.
-A walkie-talkie?
-Yes.
-You communicate
with people on that?
-It's February 14th.
-I'm sorry?
-It's Feb-- Sweethearts.
-Oh, my God. Valentine's Day.
Valentine's Day.
-Oh. Uh...
♪♪ I'm in love with
the shape of you ♪♪
-What?
[ Laughter ]
-I just sang it.
I have red hair.
I'm an Irish singer.
I'm friends with Taylor Swift.
-What?
-Uh, I can't think
of any of his songs.
Like...
[ Singing indistinctly ]
Stuff like that.
I'm in love
with the shape of you!
His name is --
It's like an old-man name!
-I don't know music!
[ Buzzer ]
♪♪♪♪
-Who is it?!
-It's Ed Sheeran.
-Oh...crap! I love him!
Sorry, Ed.
-Ed Sheeran.
-Yeah. Too bad, bud. Sorry.
-No, no.
There are still rounds.
-Man, I couldn't even get...
-I feel bad for
celebrating after that.
-Well, here we go.
All right. Here we go.
Ready, pal? We got this.
-Yeah.
[ Beeping ]
-Clue number five.
-Okay.
If you don't see this
coming in a fight --
It comes from behind.
You're like --
-A sucker punch.
-Yes! Nice.
See, now we're getting it.
That was great.
-Okay. Okay. A vegetable.
And it --
It makes you see in the dark,
but a small version.
Carrot. Carrot. Mini carrot.
Baby carrot.
-Yeah, that's it.
-Okay. It's a kind of spider
with a lot of --
-Tarantula.
-No.
It has many, many --
-Long-legged spider.
Daddy long legs!
-Yes!
-Oh, man! Uh...
This is when you --
It's a big --
When you grab somebody big
with love.
-Bear hug.
-Yes.
-The movie where
all the girls are singing.
-"Pitch perfect."
-Yes.
-Oh, oh, not Kevin Hart,
but the bigger guy.
-The Rock.
Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson.
-Okay, um --
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh, my gosh.
-Oh, no!
I had it, too.
-Guys, we just heard
from the judges.
We're gonna play one more round.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And this is worth...
10,000 points!
-10 million points!
-Okay. Here we go. Very good.
Whoever wins this
wins 10,000 Bitcoins.
-We have not agreed
on the prize. Okay.
[ Beeping ]
-Go.
-Um, uh,
they are not losers, but...
-Winners.
-No.
-The President
uses this word a lot.
-Fakers?
-Losers. Unh-unh.
-Oh. Huge.
-Still ends the same way.
-"Oozers."
-Um, they are --
-Snoozers, newsers.
Fake newsers.
-No, no, no.
Losers and --
-Losers and --
-Like, girls in junior high
say this about people, like...
[ Laughter ]
-Losers.
-Ahh! Losers.
The President loves this word!
To not love, but to...
-Hate!
-Yes.
-Haters!
Yes.
-Haters gonna hate.
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, check this out.
I'm old-timey!
-Old-timey mustache man.
-Yeah. What's it called?
-It's a -- It's a mustache.
-Yup, but what kind?
-A handlebar mustache.
-Yeah.
Okay, if I'm, like,
giving you attitude and --
[ Buzzer ]
-Ohh! Ohh!
-Ohh.
The winners right there.
Andrew Garfield
and Steve Higgins.
♪♪♪♪
Throwing shade.
I'm sorry about that.
-It's okay. No, please.
-We did well.
-The antonym is a thing.
-You did good!
-Our thanks to Andrew Garfield,
Rachel Brosnahan.
We're talking to Andrew
after the break. Stick around.
Haters gonna hate.